très simple dont spansion $ au centre de
la polémique des propriétaires de salles
vincent guzzo sera le seul au québec à
présenter omprend le film controversé
anti avortement il a pris sa décision au
nom de la liberté d'expression
lui qui est favorable à l'avortement je
pense que c'est un film super
qu'américain catégorie 2b que si c'était
pas pour la controverse qu'on a voulu y
faire je pense que beaucoup de monde que
running pas pensé dans les lois
cineplex a décidé de ne pas diffuser le
film au québec mais le présentera dans
quelques salles
ailleurs au pays le film untold a
soulevé le véritable tempête aux états
unis cette fiction basée sur un fait
réel raconte l'histoire débit johnson
une directrice de cliniques d'avortement
qui devient militants pro-vie la
ministre mélanie joly a critiqué vincent
guzzo
en écrivant que son choix de présenter
le film est une décision politique pour
faire reculer le droit des femmes
moi ce que je vous dit fondamentalement
c'est que la diffusion de films là a des
répercussions parce que c'est une
campagne de propagande importé des états
unis qui visent à influencer les femmes
sont des bases morales pour les empêcher
de prendre des décisions éclairées
c'est baveux et ça démontre le mépris
qu'elle a soit pour moi mais pour
monsieur madame tout le monde qu'elle
veut pas qu'on voit le film pro vie le
livre de documents pour le président de
la campagne québec-vie ce film basé sur
la vie de l'icône pro-vie et bill
johnson contribuera à rouvrir le débat
sur l'avortement au pays
je pourrais dire qu'elles représentent
que la société était ou est maintenant
comme le québec c'est abidjan l'ancien
davin et ça peut être la vie johnson
d'après le québec peut se transformer
mais un besoin d'être touchés de la même
manière au contraire pour véronique
pronovost le film contribue à diffuser
des contre vérités sur l'avortement
le problème avec ça c'est que ça vient
si maîtrisé les deux positions comme si
justement le fait de doboj pro-choix
moins chouette choix et comme tous les
deux les deux positions idéologiques se
valaient alors qu'un jeune qui est
vraiment davantage basées sur les
croyances et de l'autre côté on a la
position pro choix qui elle est
argumentée et tafer et qui est
qu'il estime justement par pardonne
toutes les études en fait la suite du
débat vendredi alors que le film prendra
l'affiché ici navy alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal